one of my goals for this year is to talk
to people
that a lot of people really don't like
are you going to share with us
and here i am
but peop people that are in prison right
major political leaders
i've been thinking a lot about
how to talk to really difficult
controversial figures
but
find together something with them that's
deeply honest about their nature about
the
ideas they have about the world like
reveal something real
and some people you have to be very
careful some people are very good at
hiding the reel inside them even from
themselves
that's something i think about a lot i
think about dictators of the past and i
put myself in the mindset well how do
you reveal something real
about this person to themselves i think
that to me and you kind of spoke to that
but
uh a great conversation is one one where
both of you discover something new like
uh it's not just
so i love that
too that's my favorite thing what you
mentioned which is allowing your
curiosity ask all kinds of questions and
get excited and to learn from an expert
but also
to push them to discover something about
themselves about their ideas
together and then that discovery
and sometimes it's uh
like
we don't see it in the moment
but the audience hears it it's weird to
say like
i would compare it to when you're a
musician you're playing with other
musicians you lose yourself in the
moment yeah it's all it's like it's
working right it's working but you don't
really
uh
see the big picture
impact of what is working right actually
feels like and that's where the audience
uh can could see that like if you talk
to somebody evil
uh
you know for me as an interviewer i have
to empathize with that person if i want
to understand i have to put myself in
that mind space and to put yourself in
that mindset you really have to become
that you have to pl you have to
understand the evil inside of you
like you have you can't just think if
somebody's in power and has
used that power to abuse others you
can't just be a
i personally a person who seeks to
understand you can't just be a
journalist asking generic questions you
have to put yourself in a place
where you're somebody who's given a lot
of power
and slowly you start to abuse that power
and what does that person become who are
you i have to plug myself into those
moments in my life in the past where
i've been angry at something
uh
and
where i've been cruel because i was
angry in little ways but then you
magnify them at scale and i have to have
to go there and that's very human and
then i have to look at another person
from across the table for me and
understand well you're there too
and then you had more opportunity to do
truly cruel things and and then um
and then where like i have to plug
myself into places where i've been i can
imagine i can go where i was cruel to
others and was unaware of it
so i was in my space where i was
thinking that i'm doing good and i was
doing not good
again i've never gotten the opportunity
to do any of those things at a large
scale but all of us have done it at a
small scale sure and i plugged myself
into that
and then we're we're here or two if it's
somebody who's in prison if it's
somebody who's a dictator we're in that
space
where evil is
is all of us have the capacity to do
that evil and i have to imagine myself
being able to do that evil
and then we're here together in that
dark dark place
and then if it if it's just right
something real can actually come
something from that person's childhood i
may be awakening to uh
realization that i thought it was a good
person and i'm not
and
for that only happens when you truly
empathize those moments of discovery are
beautiful but they also happen in
science when you have a conversation and
you realize uh i feel like talking to
stephen wolfram i feel like we
constantly realize
beautiful things together on this
element of um
you know evil and sociopathy that you
know jung had this notion that
we have all things inside us
and that we all have the capacity to be
good or evil etc um
but i have a
good fortune of working with somebody
who
has deep understanding of psychiatry but
also psychoanalysis and jungian theory
and um and he said to me recently he
said you know whether or not all people
have all things inside them is still
debated in the psychology community and
in the neuroscience community
and as a matter of philosophy but
there are certain people not many but
there are certain people for whom
they've actually lived out many versions
of their possible selves
in the first person and so those are
unique individuals then even if they
tapped into these things that as you
mentioned as a at a more minor level as
opposed to
impacting people negatively at a at
scale so being able to access those
different parts of oneself is key and
you've been willing to step into that
you know my podcast is not one in which
we we get down to those matters
but yes you never know we might do an
episode on on narcissism and sociopathy
the other thing that i took away from a
conversation with a friend who was a did
a lot of years in special operations in
the intelligence community he said you
know it's if you look at somebody's past
at some point
you will come to understand some pretty
good reasons as to why they became who
they are
but you have to draw the his words the
red line someplace and what he was
referring to was the fact that certain
people at least in the eyes of certain
communities deserve to be eliminated
as a consequence of their
actions right regardless of what drove
them to those actions so it gets right
down to the line between psycho nature
nurture uh neuroscience and
the law and justice
complicated complicated themes
you